voilà une émission 100% consacrée à
cette élection présidentielle à trois
jours du premier tour et d'autres
experts qui m'ont rejoint sur ce plateau
Béatrice Giblin bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes géographe directrice de la revue
Hérodote revue de géographie et de
géopolitique Jean Gary historien bonsoir
bonsoir président et Comité d'histoire
parlementaire votre livre la tentation
du Sauveur aux éditions Payot vous avez
un peu piqué le titre de de la tentation
du clown le livre de Laetitia cruppa
sauf que moi j'avais déjà comment dire
populariser cette idée dans un article
qui a déjà alors peut-être que c'est
Laetitia que vous avez piqué bon bah je
sais pas du tout
la tentation du Sauveur allez on revient
à à ma présentation pierre latrie
bonsoir vous êtes chef de groupe chez
Ipsos laetitia est resté à mes côtés
évidemment alors avant on va on va
vraiment consacrer une large pas de ce
débat à la campagne d'Emmanuel Macron
mais je voudrais on vient de grâce à
Sandra serrequeira de passer cinq
minutes passionnantes voilà à revivre
les moments fort de cette de cette
campagne Béatrice Gibelin c'est quoi
l'image forte pour vous le je sais pas
la déclaration meeting qui vous restera
cette campagne de premier tour c'est une
image négative c'est le meeting raté de
Valérie Pécresse c'était vraiment
terrible peut-être c'est en tant que
femme que je réagi mais avoir bon c'est
quand même une femme politique qui est
en politique depuis 30 ans
et qu'elle soit aussi démunie devant
cette salle de 7000 personnes ça sonnait
faux c'est rien n'était bon là-dedans
franchement rien et c'est où je crois
l'image oui c'est pas une page positive
c'est une image négative mais mais
vraiment et là ça a dérapé fortement
elle était bien meilleure Porte de
Versailles dimanche mais c'était trop
tard oui ou meilleur dans les débats
politiques d'ailleurs on l'avait on
avait vu dans plusieurs débats non mais
peut-être que c'était impressionnant
d'avoir 7000 personnes tout d'un coup
face à soi et et qu'elle n'était pas
préparée pour ou
ou que dans sa dans son discours il
fallait qu'elle tienne à la fois du
cioti pour une part et à la fois de d'un
centre droit républicain peut-être et
qu'elle n'a pas réussi à trouver le ton
juste c'est à dire qu'au fond on n'était
pas elle-même peut-être que le malaise
était peut-être finalement le
l'incarnation d'un grand écart politique
et du coup elle avait pas sa liberté de
mouvement peut-être jean-gary est-ce que
cette campagne vous fait penser à un
autre scrutin présidentiel ou alors elle
est vraiment atypique bon d'abord elle
est elle est atypique du fait de
l'Ukraine de du poids qui a pris la
guerre d'ukrain dans la formation
peut-être que certains médias d'ailleurs
sont coupables ce n'est pas votre cas
mais de ne pas suffisamment parler de
des enjeux politiques et de la vie
politique mais pour le reste on pourrait
faire des parallèles avec celle de 2002
ou
c'est une élection dont on annonçait à
l'avance le le deuxième tour alors
c'était différent parce que là
s'affronter un président de la
République et son premier ministre et
puis c'était droit de gauche mais il y a
des points communs la dispersion de la
gauche le la certitude de la certitude
et puis et puis au dernier moment
quelque chose qui qui est une surprise
donc un peu de ça le désarroi aussi des
électeurs parce qu'effectivement
pour ce premier tour de 2002 ça a été un
des un des plus plus tôt plus faible
pardon toute participation et c'est tout
à l'heure avec Marion Vigo donc vous
vous trouvez quand même un certain
nombre de de parler avec bien voir des
parallèles toute façon il y a aussi des
il y a de toute manière des parallèles
avec les présidents sortants alors il y
a deux cas de figure c'est celui enfin
qui ressemble le plus c'est celui de
Valéry Giscard d'Estaing 1981 et Nicolas
Sarkozy en 2012 qui n'ont pas pu être
réels je veux pas souhaiter la même
chose
il s'inspire de Mitterrand 88 donc voilà
mais sauf que Mitterrand avait
l'avantage en 1988 il n'était pas au
pouvoir
des dernières années je des deux
dernières années moi je ressens je le
ressens comme ça et un peu de la même
façon pour Jacques Chirac en 2002 alors
là c'était 5 ans de cohabitation donc
forcément il t'a encore moins comptable
du bilan des dernières années Laetitia
dans notre premier débat vous nous avez
rappelé des des mots clés de la campagne
est-ce qu'il y a une image qui ressort
je sais pas un meeting un déplacement
Éric Zemmour et c'est son sa vidéo son
entrée en campagne avec cette vidéo
voilà qui était un objet politique non
identifié et pour moi c'est un objet
politique total parce que il y a la
lignée dans laquelle il s'inscrit et
qu'il revendique des populistes Trump
bolsonaro il va même jusqu'à Orban et
puis il y a toute la symbolique aussi
qui entoure ce type de candidature qui
pour les démocraties ont été des crash
test il y a la violence la radicalité du
discours et puis euh le code un peu des
séries avec la héroïsation des
personnages politiques et sur ce sujet
pour faire court je vous renvoie à
l'excellent ouvrage le dernier de
Raphaël Lorca qui s'appelle les nouveaux
masques de l'extrême droite sous-titres
c'est le sous-titres que j'adore la
radicalité a l'air Netflix ça veut tout
dire voilà comment un vieux mouvement
d'extrême droite nostalgie qui charrie
les idées du Front national réussit à
être contemporain avec les codes
d'aujourd'hui de notre époque pierre
Latry votre dernier baromètre je
voudrais d'abord avoir le chiffre de la
participation j'ai cru voir qu'elle
remontait légèrement elle est remontée
elle remonte légèrement c'est à dire que
le dernier chiffre qui est le chiffre
des Français qui nous disent qu'ils sont
certains d'aller voter ce n'est pas une
projection de participation il est de
72%. donc c'est à dire que ça remonte
légèrement mais c'est quand même en
dessous du de ce qu'on mesurait en 2017
et surtout en 2017 on avait une hausse
dans les 12 dern jours alors que là oui
on a une hausse depuis hier en fait et
donc ça veut dire que potentiellement on
peut encore avoir un sursaut de
mobilisation et qu'on peut avoir plus
d'électeurs que prévu qui se rendent aux
urbes dimanche mais par rapport à 2017
on est quand même dans une dynamique
plus faible et alors si on regarde les
scores des principaux candidats on a
dans votre dernier rolling un Emmanuel
Macron a 26 et demi Marine Le Pen est à
23 et car se resserre Jean-Luc Mélenchon
est à 16 et demi ensuite on a Éric
Zemmour et Valley Pécresse execo pour
l'instant à 8 et demi Yannick Jadot a 5
et demi c'est votre baromètre avec sopra
Steria pour France Info et et le
Parisien mais si on pourrait donner la
suite
on va on va se centrer sur sur ceux qui
sont au-delà de 5% quand même
quelles leçons vous tirez alors là on
est vraiment c'est tous les jours vous
proposer un sondage pour pour le
Parisien et français parce que ce qui
est intéressant c'est les évolutions
c'est surtout les tendances qui sont
intéressantes le chiffre du jour aussi
mais les tendances particulièrement et
la tendance évidemment marquante là
c'est la hausse de Marine Le Pen sur ces
derniers jours qui est très importantes
parce que dans un sondage quotidien on a
un point comme ça jour après jour ça
fait quand même beaucoup donc elle est
là vraiment elle monte clairement elle
monte et elle se rapproche beaucoup
d'Emmanuel Macron qui lui a tendance à
stagner et qui voit depuis maintenant
trois semaines son intention de vote se
réduire un tout petit peu mais bon qui
reste quand même très élevé et qui reste
quand même à la première place et
Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui monte aussi de
nouveau un tout petit peu mais qui là
sont quand même assez loin de Marine Le
Pen maintenant je vous pose la même
question que Pierre Adrien Bartoli pour
Harry s'interactive dans notre premier
débat quelle est la la marge d'erreur
d'indécision dans un dans vos sondages
aujourd'hui c'est on est à trois jours
du premier tour est-ce qu'elle est
encore majeur vous parlez souvent de
fluidité des intentions de vote il y a
deux il y a il y a plusieurs choses
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a déjà l'abstention
évidemment
la participation va avoir un impact sur
la ou quand on voit notamment pour les
électorat de Marine Le Pen c'est surtout
là-dessus que ça peut se jouer c'est un
électorat assez abstentionniste donc il
y a déjà cet élément là si les lecteurs
abstentionnistes ne vient pas elle
risque de faire un score plus faible et
ensuite on a quand même encore 30 % des
Français qui qui expriment une intention
de vote qui nous disent qu'ils ne sont
pas certains de leurs choix donc on voit
qu'il peut y encore avoir pas mal de
mouvements et notamment à gauche c'est
notamment à gauche que cette incertitude
est la plus forte sur la question du
vote utile pour Jean-Luc Mélenchon alors
on va je vous propose un focus un gros
plan sur la campagne la dynamique
d'Emmanuel Macron avec cette question
peut-il rater la finale elle est un peu
provocatrice quand on voit les derniers
sondages mais après tout des surprises
il y en a eu d'autres dans notre
histoire politique c'est Pierre-Henri
holderbaum qui pose les enjeux
Emmanuel Macron prenait le large dans
les intentions de vote au premier tour
au lendemain du déclenchement de la
guerre en Ukraine le 24 février dernier
il ne cesse de grimper atteignant les
30% Marine Le Pen elle pointait en
moyenne à 14 % mais depuis plusieurs
quoi que font chuter le président
sortant dont la ferme à kinssey et
l'écart se resserre entre les deux
prétendants à l'Élysée 4 points les
séparent l'hypothèse une victoire de
Marine Le Pen ne peut en aucun cas être
écarté Marine Le Pen n'a jamais été
aussi proche du pouvoir ce qui est même
paradoxal c'est que Emmanuel Macron se
situe se situe un niveau élevé et même
très élevé au premier tour il est plus
haut qu'il ne l'était il y a quelques
mois et il pourrait être à l'issue du
premier tour à un niveau plus élevé que
son score de premier tour de 2017 donc
il a en quelque sorte élargi sa base
mais si il a élargi sa base au premier
tour il a en réalité une capacité de
rassemblement au deuxième tour qui est
significativement amputé si l'Ukraine la
portait ici une inquiétude s'est en
revanche installée celle du pouvoir
d'achat cela faisait déjà quelques
semaines que toutes les préoccupations
qu'on observait habituellement en termes
de d'environnement notamment de sécurité
d'un plusieurs semaines qu'elles ont été
reléguées et totalement écrasées par la
préoccupation du pouvoir d'achat avec la
clé du crinienne et l'impact que les
Français ont identifié sur la question
du pouvoir d'achat chez nous
effectivement cette préoccupation a
encore creusé l'écart avec les autres et
paradoxalement
le pouvoir d'achat c'est une façon de
poser la question sociale qui aurait pu
favoriser la gauche et en réalité elle
favorise Marine Le Pen d'autres raisons
semblent également faire chuter Emmanuel
Macron dans les sondages une annonce de
campagne tardive et un manque de débat
que lui reproche l'opposition personne
peut reprocher au président de la
République d'être au sommet de l'OTAN ou
de l'Union européenne dans cette
circonstance et pas de ne pas être en
médecine je pense pour ma part que un
seul meeting était insuffisante et que
par ailleurs la présence dans les il y a
ne doit pas se faire comme elle se fait
aujourd'hui de manière si il a fait une
campagne trop économe il est il est dans
une une économie permanente de la
participation à la campagne et donc ça
crée un sentiment d'éloignement des des
électeurs dans un duel au second tour
entrée manuel Macron et Marine Le Pen un
sondage interactive révèle que la
candidate du rassemblement national
réduit encore l'écart
48,5% contre 51,5 pour le président
sortant c'est intéressant parce que
c'est une leçon d'humilité vous vous
avez un écart un peu plus large c'est ça
c'est 47 53 enfin voilà un tout petit
peu plus large mais enfin ça veut dire
quelque chose on a un peu répondu dans
notre premier débat mais de poser la
question à des électeurs du premier tour
sur ce qu'ils vont voter au second alors
qu'ils savent pas encore qui sont
vraiment les finalistes
bah oui évidemment puisque le il y a ça
a quand même un impact c'est déjà le
second tour un impact sur le vote du
premier tour c'est à dire que la
perception du second tour peut avoir un
impact sur le vote du premier tour c'est
évident que si on se dit que le candidat
a une chance de battre Emmanuel Macron
au second tour ou qu'Emmanuel Macron a
une chance de battre Marine Le Pen on va
peut-être changer son vote au premier
tour donc ça a du sens effectivement à
ce niveau-là notamment alors l'accès de
campagne d'Emmanuel Macron comment vous
la jugez
encore qu'il ait fait campagne pour
juger quelque chose parce que vraiment
c'est une campagne à minima de minima
je crois que bon c'est peut-être il a
été présomptueux sans doute que annoncé
quand même en tête depuis octobre dans
tous les sondages systématiquement il a
dû se dire bon ben ça va puiser et puis
il y avait des sujets d'importance à
traiter c'est incontestablement dont il
devait s'occuper en janvier parce que
l'histoire de l'Ukraine ça démarre le 24
février l'invasion mais en fait dès le
début l'Ukraine il est va avoir Zelinski
il va avoir petit ils discute avec les
les responsables européens il prend la
présidence bref
de l'Union européenne présence tournante
qui est une opportunité et donc c'est
aussi pour ça qu'il va pas rentrer en
campagne trop tôt parce qu'il veut
d'abord rester le symboliquement le
président de l'Union européenne pendant
le plusieurs semaines les trois
premières semaines de janvier mais il se
trouve qu'à la fin janvier on est déjà
dans une configuration sur une menace
russe est-ce que quand même on a un
afflux des trous pour russe depuis
décembre mais même avant puisque ça va
commencer dès septembre et puis ça monte
et puis on a des Américains qui disent
mais vous savez c'est pas pour rire ils
vont vraiment y aller bon donc on a
vraiment une montée en en menace si vous
voulez
absorbe véritablement le président et
qui à ce moment je te dis mais je suis à
la tête de l'Europe c'est l'Europe qui
est menacée je dois y aller je dois tout
faire pour essayer d'eux et comme il est
en tête dans les sondages
ça l’inquiète pas trop de s'occuper
vraiment de de ça au lieu de faire
campagne et d'une certaine façon
qu'aurait dit les Français s'il avait
fait que campagne et s'il avait laissé
tomber l'international avec cette menace
là je suis persuadée qu'on aurait
discours non mais vous vous rendez
compte vraiment on va à quoi ça rime il
s'occupe pas de quelque chose d'aussi
important que donc de toute façon il
pouvait difficilement mais mais qu'il
soit pas allé assez au contact des des
Français sans aucun doute un seul
meeting qui fait d'ailleurs un moment où
le lendemain on va commencer à compter
très très précisément sur les radios et
sur les télévisions le temps de parole
c'est à dire que l'éco possible
c'était quand même une
erreur de débutant presque je trouve ce
genre de choses et puis ces deux débats
de départ à Poissy complètement organisé
avec bon qui qui sont tous enfin un vrai
débat et c'est prendre vraiment les gens
pour les imbéciles ce qui sont pas tout
à fait donc je pense que ça c'est aussi
une erreur puis une troisième erreur
c'est peut-être qu'il veut vraiment
séduir à droite mais il va avoir besoin
de son centre gauche et la retraite à 65
ans parler des enseignants comme il en a
parlé le RSA en échange de d'activité on
se demande d'ailleurs comment ça pourra
se faire et qui contrôlera ça enfin bon
c'est vraiment des marques très très
fort à droite
qui que je trouve maladroite il aurait
dit ces quarante annuités pour avoir
droit à la retraite et on parlait pas de
62 de 6 endroits de 64 ou 65 ans
Laetitia comment vous analysez vous la
stratégie médiatique du candidat Macron
alors je sais que c'est pas objectif
l'une c'est objectif zéro risque vous
avez tout à fait raison c'était son
intuition première ne pas faire de débat
refuser de toutes les confrontations
avec ses adversaires et puis ça c'est la
conséquence directe à faire un plan
média des plus classiques alors on l'a
vu lundi à France Inter parler aux
enseignants là il a parlé aux
enseignants quasiment toute l'interview
donc il y a les pour ça TF1 hier soir il
a pas dit grand-chose à part un petit
défense en fond de cours sur l'affaire
dites McKinsey mais sur le recours au
cabinet de conseil dans la presse Le
Figaro aujourd'hui ou il s'adresse
effectivement aux électeurs de droite en
s'inscrivant vous l'avez vu dans les pas
de Nicolas Sarkozy il assume carrément
une filiation avec l'ex président de la
République et puis demain le Parisien on
prend les paris il va parler pouvoir
d'achat certainement parce qu'il
s'adresse au lectorat du Parisien et
puis il y aura en toute fin de semaine
demain soir 19h une interview avec brut
il était déjà allé tous les candidats
sont passés mais c'est le et donc il
prend cette place et puis il a surtout
l'occasion avec à 19h cette exposition
de tourner tout le week-end sur le
numérique mais alors son grand meeting
justement finalement il a été diffusé où
il a été diffusé sur France 2 dans
l'émission politique où il a refusé de
se rendre alors ça c'est un coup de
force alors on m'a dit qu'effectivement
ces équipes il avait vraiment
soufflé dans les plumes comment on dit
non c'est pas que c'est pas sûrs
de ces équipes parce qu'elle avait mal
calculé effectivement les temps de
parole et donc il était furieux que son
meeting ne soit pas diffusé par toutes
les chaînes d'infos et donc il a trouvé
voilà cette stratagème pour à la place
de sa présence dire à France 2 bah
diffuser mon meeting mais c'est vrai
qu'une fine et ça dépend de quel point
de vue on se place Thomas soit on se dit
ok c'est hyper efficace finalement il
est resté fond de cours ou si on veut
être un tout petit peu plus cynique
jupitérien et d'autres diront que c'est
arrogance
et aussi d'une certaine lâcheté et ça en
politique surtout dans une course
présidentielle c'est une critique qui
peut coter beaucoup de points ça rejoint
le la question du débat de premier tour
qui lui avait été proposé que tous ces
opposants réclamaient et qu'il a assez
vite balayé refusé Jean Gary est-ce que
avec le recul c'est toujours facile le
des observateurs tranquillement assis
sur nos sur nos fauteuils mais est-ce
que avec le recul c'est pas quand même
une erreur mais j'ai bien intégré le
risque de devenir le punching ball des
11 autres pendant trois heures en prime
time à la télévision première partie de
soirée mais quand même ce qui était vous
avez raison je pense ce qui pouvait se
justifier et être opératoire pour
François Mitterrand en 1988 pour Jacques
Chirac en 2002 ne l'est plus en 2022
veut dire que ce besoin non seulement de
débat parce que des débats il y en a eu
mais de débats polémique
auquel se sont habituer notamment les
téléspectateurs du fait de certaines
chaînes d'informations d'ailleurs de
toute bon qui sont de plus en plus
prises par ce type de de de format avec
des électeurs de plus en plus
consommateurs de plus en plus critiques
ben je pense que étant donné en plus les
capacités
rhétoriques qui sont celles de
d'Emmanuel Macron il aurait très bien pu
s'y plier moi je pense qu'il a fait une
campagne qui tout double c'est-à-dire je
fais une campagne de rassembleur un peu
à l'écart du du débat comme l'avait fait
François Mitterrand génération
Mitterrand comme l'avait fait Jacques
Chirac en 2002 d'autant plus que j'ai
cette avantage là d'avoir la guerre en
Ukraine qui me place dans la position du
chef de guerre surplombant du président
qui voilà qui est au-dessus de la mêlée
sauf que cette cette
ce choix stratégique n'a pas bien
fonctionné parce qu'au contraire ça l'a
écarté sa renforcé son de président des
élites face aux face au peuple et ça
explique d'ailleurs en partie la montée
la remontée de Marine Le Pen donc il a
il a fait un kit ou double il l'a mal
joué il a commencé trop tard la campagne
il aurait dû faire plus de plus de grand
meeting vous savez il y a et alors
dernière chose il a oublié que être
faire une campagne présidentielle c'est
d'abord vendre du rêve ce qui ont réussi
ce que font Jean-Luc Mélenchon très bien
c'est ce que fait Fabien Roussel par
exemple les jours heureux etc et c'est
ce qu'il avait réussi à faire en 2017 et
cette année-là alors moi j'ai regardé
son son meeting après je laisse la
parole aux autres mais j'ai regardé son
meeting là du 2 avril il y a un moment
où il faut un peu l'armure où on
retrouve un petit peu de d'éloquence et
d'enthousiasme de de c'est au moment où
il parle de l'Europe et on peut se
demander d'ailleurs pourquoi puisqu'il
est dans un affrontement comportement
qui est l'affrontement historique au
fond entre l'ouverture l'Europe le repli
l'exclusion que représente Marine Le Pen
quand même historiquement pourquoi
est-ce qu'il n'a pas tout misé là-dessus
sur une sorte d'enthousiasme européen
d'autant plus qu'il pouvait s'appuyer
sur ce qui se passe en Ukraine et sur ce
sur la manière dont le la crise en
Ukraine a pu renforcer l'idée alors mais
oui mais bien que ça soit pas un sujet
populaire c'est c'est un sujet sur
lequel on sent qu'il a quelque part
voilà une une forme de de d'enthousiasme
alors que moi j'ai trouvé la sa campagne
minimale je l'ai trouvé un peu triste un
peu désenchantée
le coût de l'Europe en 2017 donc c'était
l'idée que ici recommencer bon bah il a
toujours rien apporté de nouveau on est
toujours dans le même oui
je suis d'accord
avec la guerre en Ukraine le problème
c'est qu'on efface quand même à une
Europe qu'on essaie d'unifier qui est
unique encombrantes pas dans le dur mais
là au moment où on va rentrer dans le
plus compliqué c'est un sérieusement en
train de se compliquer c'est pour ça
qu'il sait que c'est quand même un sujet
qui est très fragile qui est pas très
porteur finalement qui est pas populaire
dans une élection présidentielle je vous
parle français faut pas parler Europe il
faut parler parce que de il faut qu'on
parle aussi de du caillou McKinsey dans
la chaussure d'Emmanuel Macron c'est
quand même pas par rien ce rapport de la
commission d'enquête du du Sénat tout
tout le sur les cabinets de conseils
tout tous ces imposants s'en emparent
évidemment regarde de tweets un signé
Éric Zemmour il félicite la commission
d'enquête du Sénat et puis se félicite
aussi que le parquet national financier
se soit saisi du dossier on peut
regarder aussi Fabien Roussel qui lui
rappelle que c'est une sénatrice
communiste il y en assassis qui a
codirigé qui était rapporteur de la
commission d'enquête du Sénat pierre
Latry est-ce que cette polémique elle
elle imprime dans l'opinion est-ce que
c'est une sorte de je sais pas de poison
lent pour pour Emmanuel Macron ou pas
d'ailleurs je suis sûr que ça l'aide pas
ça c'est une évidence après si on
compare avec la faire Fillon de 2017 ça
n'a pas grand chose à voir on voit bien
que ça n'imprime pas tant que ça c'est à
dire que il y a pas d'enrichissement
personnel c'est quand même quelque chose
d'un petit peu complexe donc ça ne l'est
pas je pense que ça mais c'est
l'impression que ça renforce plus la
volonté de ses opposants que ça ne casse
le le ses soutiens je pense que je
reviens un peu sur ce qu'on disait je
pense qu'il y a quelque chose qui est
très important à comprendre sur le vote
pour Emmanuel Macron c'est qu'il a un
ressort qui est quand même différent de
celui des autres quand on demande aux
Français qui vont voter pour Marine Le
Pen pour Jean-Luc Mélenchon pour Yannick
Jadot pourquoi ils disent d'abord parce
que je suis proche de ces idées Emmanuel
Macron la première réponse c'est parce
que j'ai confiance en Lui c'est le seul
qui suscite la confiance qui pour qui il
y a une majorité de Français qui pensent
qu'il a la stature d'un président de la
République
fort je pense qu'il y a peut-être un
comme ça aussi dans sa stratégie c'est à
dire qu'il est oui tout Français
confondu pour le coup
c'est à dire que c'est le seul qui a
c'est une majorité et c'est une majorité
c'est le seul qui a cette majorité là en
fait d'ailleurs le canton je regardais
des sondages aussi qui étaient faits il
y a quelques semaines quand on demande
aux Français est-ce que un tel ferait
mieux que Emmanuel Macron il y en a
aucun il y en a aucun de ces en termes
de présidentialité il est largement
au-dessus des autres oui c'est vraiment
ça c'est pour ça qu'il fait une campagne
à minima je pense je pense qu'il y a un
peu de ça quand même c'est à dire que
c'est vraiment son argument numéro 1 il
est le président et il est le seul qui a
les épaules pour affronter dans une
période où on a connu et la pandémie de
covid puis ensuite la guerre en Ukraine
son argument c'est je suis le seul qui a
les épaules les autres ne les ont pas
mais en fait ce que vous nous avez
décrit tout à l'heure c'est la
quadrature du cercle il pouvait-il faire
autrement et c'est ce que je pense c'est
la peinture honnêtement il est dans une
d'abord se faire relire n'est jamais
simple on l'a dit plus d'une fois et il
est quand même dans une conjoncture
internationale mais aussi nation on sort
quand même de deux ans de pandémie ou
honnêtement les Français ont été plutôt
mieux traités que dans beaucoup d'autres
pays européens c'est incontestable bon
donc il est difficilement attaquable
là-dessus sur le sur la pandémie bon il
y a eu les masques au début mais c'est
il y a 2 ans maintenant des masques il y
en a partout donc je pense que même pour
lui si vous voulez ce qui se passe en
Ukraine ce qui ce que la Russie décide
c'est un enjeu qui est tellement
colossal dont je crois les Français
n'ont pas pris la mesure ils n'ont pas
pris la mesure des conséquences
inéluctables qu'on va avoir et que si il
y a la moindre pseudo-victoire pour
Poutine dans un délai court c'est une
catastrophe mais c'est vraiment une
catastrophe géopolitique pour le reste
de l'Europe dire que l'urgence elle est
vraiment d'arrêter cette guerre et de et
de vaincre véritablement d'avoir une
défaite de petit
essentiel c'est essentiel pour que
l'Europe tienne la route mais aussi pour
que l'Occident ne se retrouve pas mis au
banc de tous les autres États que ce
soit le continent africain que ce soit
en Asie que ce soit en Amérique latine
l'enjeu est vraiment majeur et je crois
que les Français ne le mesurent
absolument pas on est excusez-moi mais
pouvoir d'achat par les sans arrêt de
pouvoir d'achat c'est ne pas vous la
revoir prendre en compte les énormes
risques comprendre au nom de garder
notre confort et notre pouvoir d'achat
et dans quelques temps on parlera même
plus de pouvoir d'achat mais c'est
pourquoi
il est passé à côté d'un récit oui c'est
ça le problème c'est pour ça que je
parlais avec vous parce que on le voit
et d'ailleurs dans les choix des chaînes
d'infos dont vous parliez depuis
quelques jours quasiment de ne parler
que de l'Ukraine et plus de cette
campagne présidentielle
ça s'explique aussi par l'intérêt du
public donc il y a un intérêt qui reste
très fort des Français une inquiétude
qui reste très fort français pour la
question de l'Ukraine mais elle ne
profite plus électoralement à Emmanuel
Macron parce que il a raté quelque chose
je pense que il n'a pas saisi au bon
l'occasion ou de manière peut-être trop
ponctuelle de de construire son récit de
président de président sortant et de
futurs présidents potentiel de le
construire là-dessus sur le fait que
nous sommes là dans la défense d'un
certain de valeurs face à un autre type
de conception de la démocratie libérale
en fait qui est une dictature que que
nous défendons un certain nombre de
valeurs que pour défendre ses valeurs on
peut s'appuyer sur l'Europe c'est ce que
je disais tout à l'heure et qu'il a face
à lui des candidats qui eux de par leurs
liens plus ou moins avérés avec Vladimir
Poutine sont quand même très loin de ces
de ces valeurs là donc je pense qu'il y
avait un récit articulé et il n'a pas su
le le faire passer et pourquoi n'a-t-il
pas fait le récit est-ce que il est pas
donc il est capable de penser ça je
pense que c'est lié à la position de
l'Allemagne et que le fait que
l'Allemagne soit si dépendante des
hydrocarbures russes qui des choix qui
ont été faits pendant le gala Merkel on
supprimant le nucléaire regardez le mal
qu'ils ont à vouloir relancer leur
centrale nucléaire alors qu'il pourrait
faire la France a dit on vous donne le
carburant nécessaire pour les relancer
or ils ont énormément de mal à
il voulait pas prendre le risque de se
couper de l'Allemagne mais c'est pas
possible président de l'Union européenne
il ne peut pas se trouver de l'Allemagne
ce n'est pas possible donc vous nous
décrivez une campagne impossible en fait
pour être Macron c'est vraiment
intéressant quand on fait la somme des
des freins ou des boulets on peut parler
de boulet il peut il peut pas se
permettre en ce moment de faire une
campagne avec une forme de rupture avec
avec je vous propose ça va vous plaire à
un coup d'oeil dans le rétroviseur des
des campagnes présidentielles
précédentes il y a toujours des
enseignements à tir Marion Vigo vous
pouvez revenir à nos côtés zoom sur ces
élections qui se sont jouées dans un
mouchoir de poche oui puisque si
certains prédisent un duel Macron Le Pen
pour ce second tour il faut se rappeler
que en 2002 le duel j'ose pas Chirac
apparaissait comme une évidence et on se
souvient de cette stupeur à l'annonce
des résultats du premier tour je vous
propose d'ailleurs de découvrir quelques
images à l'antenne les images des
réactions dans le camp socialiste après
l'élimination de leurs candidat Lionel
Jospin en profit donc de Jean-Marie Le
Pen une élimination sur le fil c'est le
premier tour le plus serré la Cinquième
République et on va regarder les scores
Lionel Jospin était éliminé avec 16,2%
des voix et Jean-Marie Le Pen qualifié
avec 16,9% des voix seulement à 200 000
voix séparent les deux hommes Jacques
Chirac est en dessous des 20% avec 19,9
c'est d'ailleurs l'un des scores les
plus faibles pour un candidat qui arrive
en tête au premier tour ici la marge
d'erreur des sondages est liés à
l'abstention que les sondeurs n'avaient
pas vu venir et qui a été
particulièrement élevé et qui s'est donc
fait aux dépenses du candidat socialiste
en 2002 cette abstention elle était de
28,4% au premier tour un taux qui n'a
pas été égalé depuis autre élection avec
de faibles écarts entre les candidats
celle de 2017 une élection qu'on connaît
bien et je vous propose de revoir un
extrait de cette soirée du premier tour
avec l'annonce des résultats c'était sur
notre antenne
rez
ces deux vitres
23,7% elles se sont les estimations du
premier tour suivi par Marine Le Pen la
candidate du Front national qui
obtiendrait toujours pour selon nos
premières estimations
Ipsos 21,7% des suffrages voilà voilà
pour ces deux candidats qui se détachent
en tête regardez les candidats suivants
François Fillon 19,5 a égalité avec
Jean-Luc Mélenchon 19,5 donc c'est
évidemment éminemment serré voilà cette
évidence serrée pour les deux autres
Siders François Fillon et Jean-Luc
Mélenchon qui obtiennent en finalement
20% et 19,6% des voix il leur aura
manqué respectivement entre 400 000 et
600 000 voix pour se hisser au second
tour ce qui fera notamment dire aux
candidats de la France insoumise pendant
toute la première partie de cette soirée
électorale qu'il existe une incertitude
sur les résultats le candidat insoumis
qui espèrent bien prendre sa revanche
cette année et se qualifier alors on
monte un peu plus loin dans le temps
encore on est dans les années 90 avec
l'élection présidentielle de 1995 de
candidats de droite se présente c'est le
duel fratricide entre Édouard Balladur
alors Premier ministre et Jacques Chirac
président du RPR un duel finalement
remporté par Chirac qui se qualifie au
premier tour avec
20,8% des voix contre
18,6% pour Édouard Balladur le
socialiste Lionel Jospin sera l'autre
finaliste avec 23,3% des voix à Lionel
Jospin qui s'inclinera finalement au
soir au second tour face à Jacques
Chirac qui entamera lui son premier
mandat présidentiel merci beaucoup
Marion c'est toujours passionnant de
revivre ces ces moments là effectivement
moi ce qui me
m'intrigue quand même pierre latrie si
on se projette un peu vers le second
tour et si je reprends la question que
j'ai affiché dans ce débat depuis le
début
Emmanuel Macron peut-il rater le coche
et ne pas se qualifier pour la finale
est-ce que l'écart entre lui et celui
qui pour l'instant est le troisième
homme on va être très prudent évidemment
ça peut changer Mélenchon et trop
important d'après vous à trois jours du
scrutin ça me semble quand même
invraisemblable invraisemblable très peu
probable je sais que j'ospin avait dit
la même chose quatre jours avant le
premier tour mais ça me semble assez peu
vraisemblable pour une bonne raison
aussi c'est que en 2002 quand Lionel
Jospin qui est donné au second tour et
finalement éliminé faut pas oublier que
la gauche social-démocrate fait un score
important en fait c'est à dire que
Lionel Jospin certes lui fait un score
faible mais il y a quand on cumule
Christiane Taubira Jean-Pierre
Chevènement c'est un score important là
Emmanuel Macron il n'a pas de de
personnalité à peu près équivalentes qui
pourraient être ou d'un coup faire 5-6%
parce que les gens ont envie d'un peu de
fantaisie ou et donc
lui prendre les voix et donc il y a il y
a pas ça donc je vois pas par rapport à
Lionel jospince qui pourrait l'empêcher
lui aussi vous vous prenez maintenant
l'abstention et vous la calculez haute
pour avoir moins de
savoir plus sur les Français qui
expriment effectivement une intention de
votre donc l'abstention effectivement
mais elle est quand on regarde le profil
des abstentionnistes ce sont surtout des
jeunes et des catégories populaires ce
qui n'est vraiment pas l'électorat
d'Emmanuel Macron qui est très élevé
chez les personnes âgées et dans les
catégories socioprofessionnelles
supérieures si ça se tiennent assez peu
donc c'est pas lui qui a le plus de
risques vis-à-vis de l'abstention
parlons stratégie Jean Gary Lionel
Jospin dans les dans les jours qui
précèdent le premier tour il y a des
voix qui s'élèvent au sein même de sa
famille politique pour dire attention
attention on va peut-être ne pas se
qualifier et il décide de de ne pas les
entendre ils décident de ne pas
communiquer sur le risque Le Pen pour ne
pas afficher sa fragilité je vous pose
cette question parce que ça ça sa
questionne pardon de me répéter mais la
stratégie de
d'Emmanuel Macron au second tour est-ce
qu'il faut qu'il brandisse la menace
d'une victoire de Marine Le Pen vous
voyez ce que je veux dire mais en tout
cas on voit bien que là depuis une
semaine beaucoup d'articles nous disent
que dans l'entourage d'Emmanuel Macron
on s'inquiète etc et on peut penser que
cette inquiétude là finalement pourrait
lui être utile pour au moins déjà pour
le premier tour parce qu'elle
remobiliserait peut-être des indices
même si il semble que l'électorat et
c'est ce que bon tous les sondages
l'électorat de de Macron c'est électorat
solide c'est un hectoral qui qui va se
qui va se déplacer mais je en
l'occurrence moi je pense que cette
fragilité là alors je dis ça parce que
je me fie il y a des choses que j'ai
entendu un peu partout cette fragilité
là elle peut plus lui être
utile me semble-t-il que que
préjudiciaire parce qu'on a tellement eu
l'impression que les jeux étaient joués
que qu'il surplombait mais c'est ce
qu'on a c'est de dire que s'intéressait
pas à cette campagne que montrer quand
même un tout petit peu que il s'inquiète
et que il faut mobiliser ses partisans
c'est quand même quelque chose qui peut
lui donner un petit coup de petit coup
de booster alors moi je suis pas
d'accord du tout avec vous Thomas il l'a
fait des sons déplacement là la semaine
dernière il a tout de suite remis sur
sur la table l'extrême droite le temps
même d'extrême droite donc il est dans
ce dans
avec Jospin c'est à dire que au moment
de Jospin personne ne croit que
l'extrême droite peut arriver
au deuxième tour
qui sont assez passionnants qui sont
tournés avec l'équipe il y a quand même
personne il y a deux trois personnes qui
me disent attention
c'était l'homme qui s'occupait
très clairement attention mais dans
j'allais dire dans la tête d'une grande
partie des socialistes comme dans celle
de Jospin c'est l'impensable c'est à
dire que aujourd'hui on peut avoir une
Marine Le Pen au deuxième tour à 48% des
voix ou 47% des voix c'était
inimaginable mais vraiment je veux dire
c'était tabou de penser voter pour pour
Le Pen regardez Chirac il est élu avec
plus de 80% des voix en 2002 c'est
pardon mais c'est imaginable d'avoir une
Marine Le Pen à 50,1% des voix et qui
devient président de la recherche je
suis tout à fait d'accord avec vous mais
ce que je veux dire par là c'est que le
contexte si vous voulez de l'extrême
droite comment l'analyse en 2002 par
rapport au contexte d'aujourd'hui en
2022 il est radicalement différent tu as
changé je suis il y a cette flambée
populiste partout dans les démocraties
et il y a Éric Zemmour qui dévia bonus
il n'est plus là
forcément plus là d'où la nécessité
d'une stratégie de la diabolisation il
faut absolument que de mobiliser parce
que il y a un électorat on sait bien que
une partie des électeurs de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon qui
rechigne à se reporter éventuellement au
second tour sur Emmanuel Macron est-ce
que même des électeurs de de gauche ou
de centre gauche vont accepter à nouveau
de a priori je le pense et je on peut on
peut imaginer que le Yannick Jadot ou on
peut l'esté pour certains peuvent
espérer donc on le redouter mais en tout
cas il y a certainement la matière et
une stratégie d'ailleurs vous avez
raison elle a commencé à diaboliser
l'adversaire une information de cet
après-midi le Parlement européen a voté
aujourd'hui à une très large marjorité
pour des sanctions lourdes contre la
Russie incluant le pétrole et le gaz
alors ça veut pas dire que ça va être
décidé par l'Europe parce que c'est la
Commission européenne qui prend cette
décision et on a bien vu que on n'en
serait pas là dans dans les dans les
heures à venir mais ce qui est
intéressant c'est que les députés
européens du rassemblement national on
fait en sorte de ne pas prendre pas ils
se sont absolus ils étaient ils étaient
pas dans dans l'hémicycérine pourquoi je
vous raconte ça parce que Pierre latrie
voudrais vous entendre sur la question
de des liens entre Marine Le Pen entre
le rassemblement national et la Russie
de Vladimir Poutine est-ce que entre les
deux tours ce qui n'a pas imprimé avant
ce premier tour va peut-être imprimer
d'après vous c'est possible parce que
c'est quand même très étonnant ce qui
s'est passé avant ce premier tour c'est
à dire que c'est Eric Zemmour qui a payé
les pots cassés de ce qui se passe en
Ukraine alors que c'est pas lui qui est
quand même le plus engagé c'est-à-dire
que Marine Le Pen il y a eu évidemment
l'histoire de l'emprunt russe mais
encore récemment cette semaine à Élisée
2022 quand on leur demande est-ce que
Vladimir Poutine peut redevenir un allié
si il quitte l'Ukraine Eric Zemmour dit
non c'est pas un allié mais je parle
avec tout le monde Marine Le Pen dit oui
donc c'est à dire qu'elle a en plus une
position encore aujourd'hui
elle a juste pas beaucoup parlé du sujet
et je pense que d'une manière générale
comme sous tout ce qui touche à
l'extrême droite française elle a été
assez épargnée pendant cette campagne
parce que c'est Eric Zemmour qui a
incarné maintenant la nouvelle extrême
droite et qui a été attaqué pour ça et
je pense que en revanche là dans votre
tour évidemment ça va beaucoup plus
ressortir
sur son position ils l'ont fait
sur les anxieux elle assume de ne pas
voter les sanctions et elle le dit
clairement elle dit je ne veux pas ces
sanctions parce que ça va se
retournera peut-être pas le duel du
second tour mais projetons-nous dans un
débat Emmanuel Macron Marine Le Pen un
remake de celui dit à 5 ans
Emmanuel Macron il a là il a la une arme
contre Marine Le Pen quand même une arme
mais elle elle a appris elle ne l'aura
pas en face de lui la même personne qui
l'a vu en 2017 elle s'est quand même
sérieusement rodée elle a été elle a été
mieux entourée
ceci étant manuel Macron est quand même
à remarquable des batteurs et quand il
efface à ce genre de situation il est
plutôt bon et il est plutôt offensif
donc et je pense qu'il va pas du tout
l'épargner mais mais elle va être
offensive et alors là où ça peut jouer
c'est que elle a joué la dédiabolisation
les petits chats la peu clair tout est
tout doux tout est tout absolument
charmant et puis là on va se retrouver
dans quelque chose qui va être beaucoup
plus frontal et elle va devoir prendre
une position qui va être beaucoup plus
agressive beaucoup plus offensive et
chasser le naturel il revient au galop
et là déjà dans les interviews
d'ailleurs ça va ça va être tout à fait
différent tout ce qui était tout sauf
tout tout mignon ça va ça va on peut
imaginer qu'effectivement la campagne
d'entre-deux-tours sera une campagne
très rude pour ne pas dire violente
parce qu'il y a tellement de lignes de
fracture qui peuvent s'exprimer dans
toutes les familles politiques en
Ukraine et que ça écrase de nouveau
toute l'actualité on suivra ça avec
patience
solidarité va aux Ukrainiens y compris
dans l'électorat de Marine Le Pen et
dire et c'est la ligne de fracture mais
j'insiste là dessus historique pour
toutes les démocraties on l'a vu aux
États-Unis et on le voit on va le voir
si beaucoup à tous la tentation du
Sauveur c'est le titre de votre livre
qui est publié
merci à tous d'avoir participé à ce